for day three of stoic week 2015 I
wanted to focus on another text by
Cicero the on duties or day a fitness
classic text having to do with with
ethics and largely from a stoic
perspective Cicero again let me remind
you is not himself a stoic he actually
at certain points identified with the
academic skeptic school but when it
comes to matters of ethics and even to a
certain extent political theory he more
off of the lines himself with the Stoics
and with the Aristotelian czar
peripatetic s-- and some of the manners
in this book in particular he really
lines himself up closely with the Stoics
against the Aristotelians so he is a
very important representative of certain
interpretations of stoicism in part
because what he's doing is well not
necessarily endorsing views himself he
will he will place them in his test in
this case it's a little bit different
this one is addressed to his son it's
not a dialogue it's rather a trees
there's a brief introduction and then
the rest of it is primarily exposition
of the issues and the doctrines and he
you know he's focusing on not athletes
there it's on referring to engaging a
middle stoic figure this guy penalty is
who had written a work on duties himself
we don't have that unfortunately all we
really have are Cicero's references to
and he had a few other classical
references as well and that gives us
what we have of that text but in this
work if you go on to read it
I am very highly encourage you to read
this this work not only for stoic week
but also because it played an important
role in the history of ideas this is
work influenced a lot of people over
over the years what we find is that
Cicero not only tells us some of the
things that that that his predecessor
had seen as the stoic who was interested
in adopting what was useful from other
perspectives like the Platonic of the
recipient perspective he tells us what
that person taught but he also
criticizes it and tries to go further
than so he tells his son going back to
the you know through the the beginning
of this then he's going to present the
ethics here or rather the parts of
ethics that have to do with duties in
particular in a more or less stoic
position he says there's only certain
schools that can actually lay a claim to
having an ethics the Stoics are one of
them I'm gonna you know trying to try to
give you the best that I can
from their perspective and he really
does he goes with a great detail in this
text he criticizes panaceas presentation
because he says Pentheus only focused on
three of these main aspects I'm gonna
focus on all fun one of them is moral
goodness and badness or in the Latin the
ho nessam and the Terr pay from which we
get turpitude right do you have ever
heard that word moral turpitude and you
wondered what that meant
it means badness it means badness in a
absolute way horn s them means good
intrinsically good
so that is them as the good for the
Stowers and then there's expediency or
usefulness should be human there and
that refers to the Latin ETA or utility
toss the word that we get utility from
and the utilitarian is later on would
pick up on that that term that is
another important consideration of
ethics and then conflicts between a
moral goodness
and expediency should you do what will
be useful or should you do what is
morally good or right this is a classic
question one that people have had to
grapple with over and over again and
again just like with the previous texts
the on the ends long after you and I are
gone you know millennia after
Cicero is gone and we have shuffled off
the stage there are going to be people
debating these questions not because
there aren't any answers to them but
because it takes time to understand the
answers and we need good guides for that
that's part of what sister was providing
us with he's going to prove on penance
uses the examination of things by saying
he left out a few important subjects
this one here how to choose between two
morally good or right options what do
you do when you're faced with two
competing goods and you don't seem to be
able to satisfy both of them like you
know he has the example somewhere in the
text thinking it's in book one then you
you made a commitment to somebody just
show up at a particular time to defend
them in court since Rome as a lawyer and
your son falls sick and is about to die
which one do you follow throughout do
you say well I made the obligation I
can't go I can't stay with my son who is
sick or do you say well you know that
obligation is going to have to wait or
somebody else will have to handle it
he'll understand you you have to choose
one or the other you can't be in both
places at the same time there is a third
option which is do nothing or go
somewhere else that Cicero doesn't
and Cicero is willing to handle these
sorts of moral dilemmas and examine them
so if you're like moral dilemmas this is
a book that you want to check out so one
of the commonly choose between two
expedient options you know when we're
talking about goods that are their goods
of expediency we're talking about things
like wealth and position do you you know
do you favor one you favor the other how
do you choose between relationships that
you yeah how do you set them in a kind
of hierarchy this is a classic question
in ethics and Cicero is grappling with
this in quite a lot of detail you can
tell this is a rather lengthy volume of
course this is the Latin on one side of
the Greek on the other respect Latin on
one side of the English I think ah
they're not degree sister was
translating Greek into Latin for for his
his audience so it's about twice as long
as it needs to be but even so it would
still be a rather you know substantial
treatise on ethics so what I'm going to
do is just focus on a few interesting
aspects of this text not trying to go
over the entire thing that would
actually take quite a lot of video
footage if I were teaching this in a
class that would take more than one
class session and what I want to focus
on in particular is Cicero's treatment
of the virtues in here and how that fits
into this question of Vickie's or moral
duties
you'll notice on the board that I have
four character traits picked out here
those were called the cardinal virtues
and the Stoics were not the first people
to organize the you know good habits of
character or good character traits the
forms distinctive forms of human moral
goodness into this schema you know we
find this for example in Plato's
Republic and we're going to see many
other people you know use this scheme of
the virtues besides the stones but the
Stoics got a lot of mileage on this and
the sister was going to in this work so
a moral goodness he says the hone asta
the that which is intrinsically valuable
has four parts or modes you might say
for human beings he says you see here
Marcus the very form and as it were the
face of moral goodness and if does Plato
says it could be seen with the physical
line it would awaken a marvelous love of
wisdom and then system goes on to say
all this is morally right arises from
some one of four sources that's how its
translated here the Latin is actually
it's an old up core test when asked them
everything that is that is morally good
that is moral goodness
in quantum our party important or X I
think why it arises out of one of these
four parts it stems from one of these
things so I use the word motive here
because that works as well you can think
of this virtue is a totality but it's
also divisible into these aspects these
different ways of being virtuous so what
are they Cicero goes on and says it's
either concerned with full perception
and development of the truth grasping of
the true by the human being we the
Cicero's think that the Stoics and
Cicero of course thing
we have a natural propensity towards
desiring truth and towards being averse
to falsehood when we recognize it as
such and that is reflected in this
wisdom is this orientation towards
attaining the truth that does in fact
attain the truth and comes to understand
comes to perceive what is true so that's
an important part of moral goodness and
he says another important part is
concerned with the conservation of
society with giving each person his or
her view giving them what they deserve
giving them what they merit and was
faithfully executing the obligations
undertaken well that part is what we
call justice and the Stoics thought that
that was incredibly important as well
Cicero is going to say that this part
right here is in service but most human
and then justice is the second most
important of these the third one
concerned with greatness and strength of
a noble spirit
well that's courage Cicero is going to
talk quite a bit about what the
conditions for real courage as opposed
to just being aggressive or being angry
are and nobility of spirit is is going
to be part of that responding to the
sorts of difficulties and threats and
hazards that will inevitably arise not
only for oneself before those whom one
cares about those who want it is
obligated to take care of and serve that
requires courage then finally the top it
off we have the virtue that is concerned
with orderliness and moderation of
everything said and done and I put and
desired here as well because later on
he's discussing temperance he is going
to say explicitly that it has to do with
our appetites it has to do with how we
subordinate our effective
our personality our drives to
rationality to living a fully rational
life so each one of these is a part of
moral goodness he goes on and he says
although these four are connected and
interwoven still it isn't each one
considered singly that certain definite
kinds of moral duties have their origin
so when we when we get to know what
indeed you know wisdom is where justice
is or courage is or temperance is and
that goes beyond just having a
definition you know that most
comprehension when we get to know this
and we get to know this in part through
you know studying and being taught but
also in part through acting through
becoming habituated by doing the right
thing so that we can then recognize what
the right thing really is and and how
you know what sort of effects it has as
opposed to its opposite when we do that
we start to realize what some of our
obligations or duties are alpha Kia are
the the things that we we are supposed
to be doing remember a thick iam is the
Latin translation of the the Greek term
that was used by people like activist
Zeno and other stomachs to mean some
sort of you know due to your obligation
to do so it goes on and says in this
category for instance which is
designated first in our vision that's
wisdom and hidden which we place wisdom
and prudence belong the search after
truth and its discovery notice what he's
saying there the search after truth and
its discovery that's not something
purely optional for human beings that's
something that's incumbent upon us it
doesn't mean we all have to become
scientists or we all have to become
moral philosophers or anything like that
but we do have to seek out truth at
least to the degree that we need it to
the degree that is going to enhance our
lives and allow us to
exercise our faculties and exercise
these other virtues in wise and prudent
ways so it's very important he says the
more clearly anyone observes the most
essential truth in any given case in the
more quickly and accurately you can see
and explain the reasons where the more
understanding and wise has generally
esteemed and justly so so it is truth
that is as it were to the stuff which
with which this virtue has to deal and
on which it employs itself and then he
says before the three remaining
merchants on the other hand is set a
different task the task of providing and
maintaining those things on which the
practical business of life depends
Cicero is very much about the practical
business of life as a matter of fact he
is going to differ from philosophers
like say Plato who would be content to -
you know contemplate the the good and
and the forms and stuff like that you
know life withdrawing from practical
life the life just wisdom Cicero says no
the active life is really much more
important that's where we we live out
our distinctively human good so even
wisdom is going to be connected with
what we can do in our life but there are
these other bridges that are directly
concerned with what we do how we get by
how many get along with other people
what we make of ourselves what we pass
on to others and so he says these are
set the task of providing and
maintaining those things on which the
practical business of life depends so
then the relations of man to man and
human society may be conserved and that
largeness and nobility of soul may be
revealed the holy increasing one's
resources and acquiring advantages for
oneself and a family but far more in
rising superior to those very things the
stoic understanding of courage is not
just about you going out and getting
everything that you need or getting
everything that your family needs it's
in part about disciplining yourself so
that you don't need quite
much so that you could live a noble life
not just a life of consumerism or a life
of competition and then he says orderly
behavior and consistency of demeanor and
saw control and they're like calves are
sphere and they have Department of
things in which a certain amount of
physical exertion and that mental
activity merely is required for if we
bring a certain amount of propriety and
order into the transactions of daily
life we shall be conservative moral
rectitude moral rightness honesta Hana
Stockton and moral dignity that dignity
that which is befitting to us so all of
these are constituents of the good life
for the Stoics they all require a lot of
work on our part in order to bring about
and you know some of that work is we
might say you know sitting down and
actually doing it kind of work making
the tough choices some of it is self
analysis figuring out you know what
makes us the way that we honor as
individuals not just as human beings and
such or classes of people and part of it
is the work of coming to think out what
obligations would stem from these now
I'm not going to talk about all of these
in the course of this video I highly
encourage you to read this book
wonderful you'll get so much out of it
if you do I'm going to focus in on two
of these and just certain aspects of
them that I find the most interesting in
this this particular work I'm going to
talk about justice and I'm going to talk
about courage and then I'll wrap up by
bringing up one other interesting
consideration that we find in this work
in cicero's portrayal of the stoic moral
theory in the duties in book 1 primarily
he talks about justice and the Stoics
very highly valued justice they saw a
great many obligations or duties
stemming from justice because it applies
in so many areas and aspects of human
life not just say family life or
financial transactions but even warfare
he talks about you know what is
allowable in war and what's not we have
the beginnings of a Just War theory here
and many responses was quite interesting
and some few things here that I want to
focus in on particular there's quite a
few pages devoted to justice and I we
got a highly encouraging committee what
is it he says that the foundation of
justice itself is with the translators
rendering as good faith or we might
actually say something like you know
loyalty or being a stand-up guy you know
she has an idiom that maybe some of us
are familiar with good faith actually
following through and actually doing
what a person ought to do fidelity and
truth he says as to promises and
agreements that is at the core of
justice there are certain things that we
either explicitly or implicitly have
undertaken and you know it's it's unjust
if we don't do those sorts of things
we have a duty we have a victim to do
things in a certain way so if I'm going
to get married to somebody I should
actually get married to them and follow
through on the commitments that I make
in getting married otherwise don't do it
you know if you don't like the bottom of
saying that you need to be faithful to
your spouse then don't get that sort of
thing going and pick some other vows
instead because if you
commit to it sister would say well you
know you're in them if I'm going to
teach a class I want to teach that class
well and I want to grade the students
fairly and we can see all sorts of other
duties sort of unfolding from this he
also talks about injustice as you know
sometimes it's a matter of actually
doing wrong to other people and then we
can say look you're being unjust you're
defrauding somebody or you're starting
money from them you're not shouldering
your fair share of the tax burden or
something along those lines
but there are a lot of cases where we're
unjust not by actively doing something
but by by choosing not to get involved
when somebody else is doing something
wrong when we have a friend for example
who is going off the deep end and we
don't you know we say well that's too
bad for them kind of a cool drama show
and watch them spiral down into the
deaths but I'm not going to get involved
because you know I don't really want to
be overstepping my bounds sister would
say well what's wrong with you is that
your friend
you actually do need to say something
then you need as we say step up there's
a lot of cases where injustice can be
done by inaction by by omission as we
call it so that's a very important point
as well I think and then he also talks
about something else that's very
interesting in this section of justice
he talks about something that we often
in in when we're thinking about our
morality
we see as going beyond the requirements
of strict justice and we can ask her
something is this part of justice or
isn't it for the Stoics it really was
part of justice if justice is understood
as a virtue as something in one's
character but a lot of people want to
say not justice just goes
far than beyond that it would be
something else like charity or
benevolence or in this case he talks
about justice itself and beneficence
then @viki MTM in latin and this benefit
ENT now this is this is going beyond
this is what we would call kindness
which is another term that he uses their
baby
that make me talk to us this translated
as kindness
literally being good to another person
Benna means means well or good
generosity Liberty Liberty tantas in
Latin generosity is doing more than
you're actually required to by the
strict rules but it is part of justice
it is part of what a good person a
person who is good in that respect this
is going to do and will actually want to
do and will almost do instinctively in
those sort of situations they don't have
to force themselves so much and we all
know what that's like
for saying this off to do the right
thing now since were said something else
that's really interesting about this he
does not endorse a sort of passion
driven enthusiastic oh I'm going to give
everything to everybody sort of approach
to this he says that really wouldn't be
fair that wouldn't be just and we're
posed with this problem who actually
does deserve or who is the best claim
who do we have a duty towards when it
comes to going above and beyond that's a
interesting question isn't it so he says
he says nothing appeals more to the best
in human nature than this but it calls
for the exercise of caution and many
particulars we must in the first place
see to a better act of kindness shall
not prove to be an injury either to the
object of our beneficence or to others
so you know giving the drug in
money to go buy drugs is not actually an
act of kindness it's a it's a mistaken
act of harming them
it's committing an injustice if you know
that somebody else has bad tendencies
and you don't give them a bunch of
armaments or a bunch of money or
resources if they're going to go beat up
on their neighbors because you're not
being good to anybody by doing that
you're just being sort of apparently
good you're putting on the this you know
the facade of goodness he says second it
shall not be beyond their means you know
there's a tendency to want to give and
that something could be in us but we
shouldn't make ourselves destitute as a
result we have to give it out a very
surplus as they say and then he says
finally and this is the most interesting
part that it shall be proportion to the
worthiness of the recipient for this is
the cornerstone of justice and by the
standard of justice all acts of kindness
must be measured so he says for those
who confer a harmful favor upon someone
they seemingly which should help are
counted not generous benefactors but
dangerous sycophants likewise those who
endure one man in order to be generous
to another are guilty of the same
injustice as if they diverted their own
accounts to their own accounts the
property of their neighbors so you know
we have to take into account the
character of the person who were dealing
with he talks a little bit more about
this later on it says the third rule
laid down was that an ounce of kindness
we should--we with discrimination the
worthiness of the object of our
benevolence we should take into a
consideration as moral character his
attitude towards us the intimacy of his
relations to us and our common social
ties as well as the services his
hitherto rendered it to our interests
you know this is a you might say well
this sounds awfully selfish but think
about it this way do you owe your
friends and family more than you know
just some random
stranger on the street if you think that
you do then you could be a stoic because
they said if Horace you know you you owe
more to them you should be you know if
you only have a certain amount of
putting up with other people's nonsense
that you can do put up with your kids
nonsense put up with your spouse's
nonsense put up with your brothers and
sisters nonsense put up with your
parents nonsense put up with your close
friends nonsense and don't worry about
those people over there if you only have
so much that you can give you need to
look for the worthiest objects of that
otherwise you're being unjust he says he
goes on and he says it's to be desired
all these considerations should be
combined at the same person if they're
not then the more numerous of the more
important considerations must have the
greater weight and he goes on he says
you know since this seems a little harsh
right he says now the men we live with
are not perfectly and ideally wise but
men who do very well if there is found
in them but the semblance of virtue
Cicero is is not as demanding as some
virtue ethicist in saying well you know
everybody needs to be virtuous all the
time he says that's actually pretty rare
that takes a lifetime to achieve so when
we're deciding who we're going to help
out were usually in a situation where
we're helping out those who are not yet
virtuous and hoping that it might help
them towards becoming virtuous and we
also look at ourselves and say we're not
completely virtuous ourselves as a
matter of fact some of us may be quite
far from it and we need to exercise in
order to get there and we can easily
identify with the other person who you
might want to show kindness to so he
says you know the more that a person is
developing towards virtue the more they
deserve to be favored now notice of the
one that it doesn't include
Berry says he says that don't mention
fortitude for a courageous spirit in a
man who has not attained perfection and
idealism is generally too impetuous it
still those other virtues that seem more
particularly to mark the good man so we
have a lot of different duties or
obligations stemming from this virtue
which we may not have at this point but
we're on our way towards if we make
efforts of justice
with in Asian culture courage was a
character trait that was particularly
value and it still is in many respects
in many parts of our own modern culture
today one of the key questions though is
well what is courage and when is a
person truly courageous the end to that
question there are many different
answers that have been given not all the
answers Matt bond to each other there
are some cases where a person seems to
be courageous but isn't really
exhibiting courage but rather or
something else something that could be
in fact a vise so Cicero on this matter
he really does take the side of the
Stoics he says encourage involves a
exultation on a lot scale spirit on him
in times of danger and this is something
that we do need we needed not only in
order to defend society in order to
protect the weak and to keep people from
being oppressed and being dominated we
also need it with respect to our own
lives and facing up to the difficulties
of the challenges that we run into you
know things ranging from you know
students who are afraid to do public
speaking to professors who you know I
see them at conferences and their
freshly minted and they're reading their
paper and their hands are shaking I just
feel bad for them watching that happen
because I remember what that was like
ready you know first starting out to you
know dealing with the specter of you
know meaninglessness or poverty all
these sorts of things that are
possibilities for us courage is
something that's needed courage is
something that gets us through that now
Cicero really stresses this second point
very strongly
he says his courage lacks justice if it
fights for selfish ends and naturally
good it's really unheard you dog it's
really the opposite it's really advice
it's really something that is morally
bad it's a it's a character trait that
we don't want to have and we shouldn't
be praising in other people as a matter
of fact courage in that sense can end up
going so far as to become the sort of
aggression that the Latins called
Cordell eat us we translate that as as
cruelty and you know if you look at what
happened in the Roman Empire you can see
all sorts of horrible examples of how
cruel people could be towards each other
sometimes saying that what they were
doing was actually courageous the Stoics
defiant courage as the virtue that
champions the cause of the rut so unless
you're actually taking up the good fight
you're not being courageous according to
the stories are according to Cicero and
then what is it it required that
requires that you first of all know what
the right thing is that you're not
totally mistaken or blinded by ambition
or avarice or lust or any of these other
things that can lead us astray or
listening to flatterers it also requires
not only that you know what the genuine
good at stake is what the right thing to
do with us
it requires that you choose it that you
commit to it that you say I will defend
this I will jump into the breach and
take the possibility of taking the hit
for those who require it it means
serving the common good the common good
perhaps of the family perhaps you know
friends perhaps of the nation as a whole
you know you talks about that as well so
we have to watch out for a couple
different things here he says from this
exultation of spirits there's a danger
because you know we're being aroused
when we're being courageous this is part
of us that gets riled up is in
that's the part that is also tied in
with this desire to dominate others
literally a competing tossa desire for
rulership so will here is a translation
of / to Nakia so you could think of
self-will as in not just being selfish
like being a greedy person but being so
assertive that you always got to get in
everybody's face that's something that
encouraged when it's not properly
regulated by justice and by wisdom can
to generate into and then it ceases to
be courage it becomes something
different
he also cautions us about about anger
and Cicero actually has quite a few
interesting things to say about the
emotion of anger I'm gonna read some of
them here I actually brought these up
last year during stoic because he says
so many interesting things he says that
here we go when were involved and strife
against other people we have to avoid
getting angry with them he says we
shouldn't listen to those who think that
one should indulge in violent anger
against one's political enemies and
imagine that such is the attitude of a
great spirited a great soul a
magnanimous in the old term brave man
says for nothing is more commendable
nothing more becoming in a Korean of the
great man than courtesy and for parents
to actually be able to treat other
people well and not to be so rough
towards them not to get so irritated
with them that's that's not you know
those sort of things are not the sign of
a courageous person those are the signs
of a angry person who that part of them
that get that [ __ ] courage should be
there instead it's just anger them
that's dominating he goes on and he says
indeed enough free people we're all
enjoying equal rights before the law we
must school ourselves to a bit
what is called mental points for we are
irritated when people have troodon us at
unseasonable hours you make a reasonable
request
we shall develop is sour churlish temper
prejudicial to ourselves and offensive
to others so gentleness of spirit and
forbearance are to be commended with the
understanding of strictness may be
exercised for the good of the state or
when when need be so there there there
are occasions where we have to act like
we're angry we have to be strict with
people but again it's only when it's
serving the common good not when it's
just advancing our own cause not when
we're being driven by passion
that's not courageous that's just being
and the jerk he goes on and he actually
says here we go if anyone proceeds in a
passion to inflict punishment you will
never observe the happy being applied
between excess and defect the doctrine
of the beam is approved by the
Peripatetic Sicilians and wisely
approved if only they did not speak in
praise of anger and tell us is that gift
bestowed on us by nature for good
purpose even reality anger is in every
circumstance to be the Raticate then is
to be desired that they who administer
the government should be like the laws
which inflict punishment not by wrath
but by justice when we have to be firm
with people when we have to be strong we
can do some of the Stoics lot without
passion without you know using anger as
kind of a crunch anger and courage are
disassociated from each other for the
Stoics he does have one other thing that
he says though I thought would be
interesting I didn't have the time to
put it up here on the board as I was
writing it but I did dog urine
he says the soul does all together
courageous and greed is marked above all
by two characteristics such a person
cherishes the conviction that nothing
but moral goodness and propriety
deserves to be either admired or wished
for or strewn after and then he want not
to be subject to any manner in
accident this is very typical stomach
views beating courageous means in part
not being out of control but being free
of the sorts of things that would be
driving us like you know when we're in
an angry state the other key thing he
says is when the soul is disciplined in
the way above-mentioned one should do
deeds not only great and in the highest
degree useful but extremely arduous and
laborious and fraught with danger both
to life and to many things that make
life worth living that is the kind of
heroic courage that the Stoics would
admire this is part of why they took
Hercules he has one of the heroes that
they sought to emulate Socrates on one
side Hercules on the other other people
like epictetus coming after cicero of
course later on so we see a very
different picture of courage here that
we might see coming from other
philosophers
towards the end of his discussion of the
virtue of temperance and some of the
other things that are allied with it
Cicero says something really quite
remarkable at least in my view and he
has to do with propriety which is how we
translate the Latin decorum that which
is befitting now which decades you know
decade is to be befitting to a
particular person and here we're talking
about individuality or the specific
nature of a person as opposed to some
other person what makes us who we are
and it says everyone should cultivate
his or her own gifts so wounds are not
vicious so you know if you think that
your gift is being saved a sister would
say yeah I don't do that
but everything else you know we're
endowed with different gifts some of us
do have a greater back towards wisdom
and other to do them a greater back
towards you know properly regularly and
courage and others do them they have a
better bang towards justice particularly
in terms of trainees what about me the
same and so we have to try to cultivate
the things that are you know most
appropriate to us that fit us the best
you know for example in doing these
videos you know I mean I do that it
turns out and taking ancient texts and
also modern texts and explaining them in
ways that people can relate to I'm not
really great at getting into debates
with people in part because then you
know prone to anger and so debates are
not a good thing for me and I used to
try to do that and it's not really my
sort of thing
other people great at that sort of thing
ask them to see what's going on in this
book and they they might be at a loss
and that's okay that's actually quite
good we don't all have to be the same
cicero's things the better fact we don't
want that we want variety we want a
human nature to show itself in as many
different ways as possible so long as
they're not vicious so he advises that
we want
follow the general laws of human nature
you know of the good they had those are
not totally different for all of us he's
not a relative mist he's not saying
everything's up for grabs we do have
certain duties that are incumbent upon
all of us but we also should follow the
particular bent of our own nature so you
know as a kid I love reading that's part
of why these books are available to me
why they speak to me the way that they
do I was fortunate and then I had
parents who you know let me read as much
as I wanted basically even while they
had lights out of time but they didn't
punish me for reading by the nightlight
afterwards some parents aren't like that
some parents have a kid who reads and
they feel threatened by it you know we
can say the same thing for musical
ability we can say the same thing for
character traits like generosity you
know if you're fortunate enough to have
a child who actually has a tender heart
and is generous the way that you know
they want to be trained that child well
don't try to stable that and it with
respect to our own selves as adults we
want to try to you know cultivate the
particular vent of our nature
Cicero does think that it's important
for us to have what he calls
what's translated here is a uniform
consistency in our life right is
equitable aside vitae but what that
means is a way of living that other
people can count on things well that's
that guy and that's the way that he he
behaves I know what I'm getting into
when I get into a conversation with them
here's where it gets really interesting
he says you're not going to have that by
copying the traits of other people and
trying to eliminate your own traits
you're not going to be able to have that
kind of you know running throughout the
whole of your life you're the same
person when you're actually
trying to put out a mask somebody else's
clothes somebody else's costume
everybody should try to be who they are
now Cicero says that requires that we
actually fulfill a certain duty he says
everyone should make a proper estimate
of his own natural ability and show
himself a critical judge of his or her
own merits and defense in this respect
we should not let actors display more
practical wisdom than we do when actors
decide what plays they're gonna do I
think about an actor going for a
audition they picked a monologue that
they can actually do well you know what
a musician is going to do a recital they
don't think the songs that they can't
plug anything the ones they do the best
well we should be like that with
ourselves we should get to know what we
are actually good at and what we're not
good at so we we can we can you know
guide ourselves right way he says shall
the planners have regard to this in
choosing his role on a stage that a wise
man failed to do this in selecting our
part in life we shall therefore work to
the best advantage in that role to which
we are best adapted if he says sometimes
stresses circumstances shall trust us
assign it to someone congenial / we have
to devote a lot of thought practice the
pain so that we can do it if not with
propriety at least with this little
impropriety as possible but if we have
the chance to to do what it is that we
individually are you might say made to
do then we want to pursue that so that
requires that we fulfill this old you
know injunction that's above the the
Temple of Apollo Qadhafi state out to
know thyself and philosophers have taken
that as you know part of the the
injunction to live the exam of life this
is part of living the examined life for
Cicero and and you know his particular
bent on stoicism is that we have to get
to know ourselves so that we can mold
ourselves into the
that were meant to be